okay as it sometimes happens on the show
we will have problems with last-minute
guest cancellations and today was one of
those days so in order to not delay
production of the show which would be
hugely disrespectful to our audience
we're going to take a few phone calls
there are a lot of people who want to
get on today and see what is on people's
minds of course the phone number is
always six one seven eight three zero
forty seven fifty let's go first to our
caller from the five two zero area code
five two zero what's your name and where
are you calling from today hey what's up
David uh this is Justin calling from
Albuquerque hey Justin what's going on
hey yeah I was just wondering your
opinion on people who become sort of a
political for one reason or another like
I've met quite a few people who like
sort of fell for the Donald Trump
rhetoric and they just affect like
decide that politics is evil in general
so what do you think that it would be
worth trying to talk those people back
into politics well so what it fell for
Trump did they vote for Trump and then
after voting for him say they're no
longer engaging in pop with politics
what do you mean yeah I mean in I mean
anecdotally but in in several cases of
people had met they voted for Trump or
they just decided that Trump and Hillary
were equivalent and I could see how they
came to that conclusion because when I
was younger I could maybe fall for that
kind of mindset but I was just wondering
if you thought it would be worth trying
to talk them into politics or if they
would maybe fall for the same sort of
rhetoric well here's the thing here's
what I think is important to explain to
those folks in the same way that not
voting is not a neutral act when you
don't vote that is a proactive decision
you make not to participate and it does
tend to help Republicans so if you're
saying I'm just not going to vote and
I'm staying out of it you're actually
typically helping the more conservative
candidate in most places who often as a
Republican in primaries you end up
helping often the most extreme
Republican in the same way you can opt
out of participating in
electoral process you can't really opt
out of politics I mean if you don't live
in the middle of nowhere in a completely
you know disconnected way in some kind
of state of nature and rural northern
Alaska or something like that
and even then this may not even apply
you are subject to what is going on
politically if you're in touch with the
financial system if you have a job if
you earn money if you have a house
whatever you are involved in politics
you might be choosing not to participate
electoral II but I think the point I
would make to people when they say I'm
just not involved in politics says
you're involved in politics you're just
choosing not to try to influence what
that looks like but either way you're
involved and affected by it that that's
the reality you can't really not be yeah
I mean that's that's a great point but
like you think that people kind of avoid
politics for like emotional reasons or
well being real absolutely lasting it's
exhausting and particularly now it's
extremely depressing and you know from
the time I'm done with the Friday show
until the weekend ends and I start
preparing the Monday show I pay
attention to no news in politics and
it's particular I understand the
instinct I just think it all ultimately
comes down to you're affected by it by
politics no matter whether you
participate or not and it's a question
of do you want to have a say or don't
you but either way you are going to
suffer from the repercussions of the
decisions made by those who are
participating and if I could quickly ask
a follow-up like if someone if you get
the sense that someone is avoiding
politics for those emotional reasons do
you think that it would be bad to try to
talk them into this because from my
perspective things have just gotten so
intense that like it's like you said you
just you have to be involved well yeah I
listen I would be an embedding involved
I would say I would be empathetic I
would say I understand that what I would
encourage them to consider is that the
short term increased involvement if we
all did it might give a significant
longer-term circumstance significantly
better longer-term service
circumstances during which we can focus
on other areas of our lives without
without having to be so worried about
what it is that's going on in Washington
that that's the argument I would make
Justin thank you I really appreciate the
call I've got a bunch of people holding
so I'm gonna let you go but I do hope to
hear from you again